hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
discuss a very widely used term in
statistics that is confidence interval
and we will see what is the significance
of confidence interval and how to
calculate it
so let's discuss the agenda for today's
session
we'll start this tutorial by
understanding estimation and confidence
intervals
then we'll move on to discuss the level
of confidence after that we'll discuss
the importance of interval estimation
and margin of error and
finally we'll learn how you can
calculate confidence interval with the
help of an example
so let's move further ahead
estimation and confidence interval
using descriptive and inferential
statistics you can make two types of
estimate about the population one is
point estimate and other is interval
estimate
a point estimate is a single value
estimate of a parameter
for instance a sample mean is a point
estimate of a population mean
an interval estimate gives you a range
of values where the parameter is
expected to lie
a confidence interval is the most common
type of interval estimate
both the types of estimate are important
for gathering a clear idea of where a
parameter is likely to lie the
confidence interval is a range of values
it is expressed as a percentage and it
is expected to contain the best estimate
of a statistical parameter
the two most frequently used confidence
interval are 95 percent and 99
a confidence interval of 95 percent mean
that it is 95 certain that our
population parameter lies in between
this confidence interval
now what is level of confidence
with respect to estimation problems
alpha refers to the likelihood that a
true population parameter lies outside
the confidence interval the level of
confidence is denoted by 1 minus alpha
and it is usually 90 95 or 99
alpha is usually expressed as a
proportion so if the confidence level is
95 percent then alpha will be equal to 1
minus
0.95 that is 0.05 now let's move on to
discuss what this confidence level means
a 95 confidence interval of the mean is
a range with an upper and lower number
calculated from a sample
because the true population mean is
unknown this rain describes the possible
values that a mean could be
if multiple samples are drawn from the
same population and a 95 percent ci
calculated for each sample we would
expect the population mean to be found
within 95 of these confidence intervals
95 percent of the sample means for a
specified sample size will lie within
1.96 standard deviations of the
hypothesis population mean similarly for
99 confidence interval 99 of the sample
means will lie within the 2.5 standard
deviations from the population mean
now let's see how you can calculate the
interval estimates
the interval estimate can be calculated
by adding and subtracting the margin of
error to the point estimate
it gives us the idea of how close a
point estimate is to the value of
parameter
the general form of the interval
estimate is
x bar plus minus margin of error
to calculate the interval estimate we
have the formula x bar plus minus z
s divided by root n
where x bar is the sample mean z is the
number of standard deviations from the
sample mean
s is the standard deviation and n is the
size of the sample
now that we have discussed the interval
estimate and the margin of error let's
understand all this concept with the
help of an example
suppose a student measuring the boiling
temperature of a certain liquid observes
the readings on six different samples of
the liquid
he calculates the sample mean to be
103.4
and if he knows that the standard
deviation of this procedure is 1.2
degrees
we have to calculate the confidence
interval of the population mean at a 95
confidence interval so using this
formula of interval estimate
x bar plus minus z into s by root n
we'll find the confidence interval
here
x bar is 103.4
and z value is 1.96 corresponding to 95
confidence interval
and standard deviation is 1.2 divided by
root 6 which is sample size so
calculating we'll get the value to be
102.47 and 104.33
which shows that it is 95 percent
certain that our population parameter
lies between this confidence interval
so with this we have come to an end to
this tutorial thank you all for watching
this session we hope you enjoyed it if
you have any questions feel free to put
them in the comment section of this
video thank you again and happy learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here